I tried to watch Ted lasso and it deeply
damaged my mental health because the
show was terrible and it was made even
worse because it made me lose faith in
humanity just a little bit more because
all these people were saying you gotta
watch Ted lasso it's a great it's
amazing it's an incredible show it
wasn't just like oh it's mildly music
people said it was incredible it's a
great show and so I sat down with my
wife and I said let's is everyone saying
it's a great show including people that
I used to trust and respect we sat down
to watch it and it was like kind of
charming for maybe a total of about 47
minutes of run time and then from then
on out it was terrible it's just it's
trite it's syrupy corny like over the
top here's what happened with the show
they had an idea for a skit but it's
like like a kind of amusing skit but now
they're trying to stretch it into
multiple seasons of a series and they
ran out of material very quickly